i hope your wedding doesn't look exactly
like that and certainly don't invite jar
jar binks may the fourth be with you
today is
national star wars day and las vegas is
doing what las vegas does best we're
celebrating with weddings and they are
themed so we are going live inside the
little vegas chapel where the force is
strong couples no longer flying solo
getting get it they're getting married
today uh michael kelly joining us live
he is the managing partner with little
vegas chapel and oh okay i thought we
were gonna see you there in costume nope
he's here hi michael good morning
hi heather hi john we're here today at
the little vegas chapel thank you for
having us
well you have to tell us what kind of
packages are being offered i know we're
hearing the star wars theme in the
background so uh that's a good start
right so yeah uh we're here uh you don't
need to be in uh in a chapel far far
away
to partake in these wedding packages
we have the
we have the i choose you wedding package
for all of you two branca fans out there
and that uh princess leia she'll preside
over the ceremony as well as receive a
star wars edited image that we've got
over here
you'll also have star wars custom music
played throughout uh the ceremony as
well as the star wars themed bouquet
and i see also we have the
yeah real quick mike i saw the the um
the storm trooper was playing the music
yes is boba fett the officiant perhaps
is is jabba the hutt handling the
catering what are some of the other star
wars aspects of the wedding
all right so yeah so princess leia uh
she'll be presiding over the ceremony
and then
she will
also include
some star wars themed vows throughout
the ceremony as well
and hopefully no lightsabers are needed
i mean you know newlyweds you want to
keep keep it nice and
friendly right so actually yeah what we
have going on right now is uh our young
padawans here they are doing the unity
sand ceremony and uh this sand is
actually very very special because we've
acquired them from the uh sands of
tatooine
oh you're in a dead valley
yeah
well michael it's all very exciting
people love their themed weddings here
in las vegas uh if you had elvis in
there as a storm trooper that might make
it like next level we appreciate it at
the little las vegas chapel there on las
vegas boulevard by the strat michael
have a good morning and congratulations
they just you are a couple and maybe the
fourth be with you yes indeed
thanks michael appreciate it
be with us